gilles hubert je suis élu sur le canton
numéro trois de la possession
vice-président donc du département et
plus précisément en termes de
délégations je suis sur tout ce qui
gravite autour de l'eau et les
infrastructures hydrauliques est
également le président m'a demandé aussi
de mener un projet sur démocratie
participative au département
de la possession ma famille est une
vieille famille de la possession je suis
très attaché à ce territoire et et
il est évident que je souhaite le
meilleur pour ce territoire de la
position au calme tient particulièrement
les actions prioritaires pour le
département lire ma délégation bien
évidemment ce sera le sujet de l'eau
deux sujets majeurs aujourd'hui la
moitié de la population de la réunion ne
bénéficie pas encore de potable robinet
il faudra faire un travail énorme à ce
sujet
bien qu'on ne soit pas directement sur
une compétence 2 du département mais le
département et contribue fortement nous
allons faire aussi un travail pour
améliorer le rendement pour qu'on
gaspille beaucoup moins d'eau à la
réunion et en on pourra dire surtout un
travail énorme sur la préservation de
notre ressource en eau
un travail également devra être
entrepris sur la démocratie
participative et faire en sorte que le
citoyen soit le plus imbriquées possible
aux décisions qui est que le département
prend pour le bien-être de sept îles
thème des parents si aujourd'hui nous
connaissons la réunion que nous héritons
de nos aînés c'est justement en grande
partie grâce à l'action des départs en
1946 il ya 75 ans maintenant la réunion
est le département est là que la
reynière connu un âge nouveau un
développement fulgurant
il ya un terme qui revient tout le temps
en 50 ans nous avons gagné 30 ans
d'espérance de vie à la réunion c'est en
résumé le bond considérable qu'on a pu
faire à la réunion et l'action du
département et bien entendu une action
déterminante je pense et je suis
persuadé que le département va continuer
dans cet axe et va faire en sorte que la
réunion de demain soit une réunion où on
va gagner
encore plus en bien-être et en
autonomie quand je parle d'autonomie je
parle de responsabilité
la réunion doit
il a travaillé là dessus et faire en
sorte que ce département puisse
accueillir de meilleure façon justement
cette population